Let's talk about
the purity rings.
For those of you who don't know,
purity rings are
worn to demonstrate
that you're abstaining
from sex before marriage
and the Jonas brothers,
they all had them.
Look, I know this is a roast
and you will think I
should be going after them.
But I think we need to set
the record straight here.
No, the rings weren't
a good idea.
Yes, as a gesture they're laughably,
toe-curlingly lame.
But remember this was
about more than a gesture.
This was about faith.
This was about principle.
This was about taking a
stand and setting an example.
Look, Joe Jonas wasn't
just sticking his fingers
in some dumb metal rings.
He was sticking his fingers in
co-stars, actresses,
and even a super model or two.